Stop getting offended
that I'm talking about the importance of women
staying home with their babies when they're born.
You don't think I know that
a lot of women cannot stay home?
I went back to work right after my first born.
I worked in the financial industry for 13 years.
I know what the markets look like right now.
I know inflation is an all time high.
My biggest thing is
we are an uninformed society.
The truth is,
if most women actually knew the psychological effect
that going to work at such an early age,
after the baby is born, has,
I'm talking lifelong impact,
they would absolutely clip coupons,
they would absolutely rely on a man,
and they would absolutely try to find a job from home.
So, yeah, I might hurt some feelings,
but at the end of the day,
if I can help one woman not regret something
and inadvertently,
positively affect a child,
I'm gonna keep talking, y'all.
Also, in my career,
I've already helped hundreds of women,
and my community for digital marketing is only growing.
The impact that this is had
not only on my life,
but on other women around me
is just insane.
So maybe you wanna boss babe it up.
Maybe you don't have kids.
Maybe you just wanna learn how to work from home
cause you hate corporate life.
All of those are very valid.
And maybe you wanna stay home with your babies.
That is valid.
That Is why I do what I do.
At the end of the day,
the money is second.
My internal incentive is really to help. Love y'all.